If conservative news were your
only source for information
You might be thinking that conservatives, and America as a whole
Are under siege by gangs of deranged, violent, blood-thirsty left-wingers
Teeming with hatred
Hell-bent on destruction
And being cheered on by the Democratic Party and the Liberal media
The Kathy Griffin beheading incident
Antifa protests
The rendition of Cesar with a Trump character
And much more seriously, the recent shooting of Republican Congressman Steve Scalise
At a Republican baseball team practice
Are all being held up as
evidence by right-wing pundits
of violence, hatred, and extremism
being rampant on the left.
And that Liberal Ideology poses a grave danger  to the country
Let' s be clear; the threat of violence from people on the left
should be of concern and monitored closely
Particularly after the shooting of Steve Scalise
but there has been a torrent of hysterical coverage
Night after night
From Fox News and other right-wing outlets
that is vastly overblown, sensationalized
Toxic and horribly hypocritical
and it ignores the disproportionately high amount of  of right-wing violence
that we have seen for many years
and unfortunately it's been pervading the narrative
among the right.
To give you a sense of just how out of hand this narrative has gotten in right-wing media,
Listen to this,
Foul language, directed right at our president,
They hate him!
And now, top Republican Steve Scalise is in the hospital.
his condition downgraded to critical.
A Trump hater, a leftist, did this.
Were it not for the bravery of police officers,
it would have been a massacre of Republicans.
There is a link between the climate of violence,
and the violent attack on Republicans.
It is a link the left should acknowledge, but they will not.
Instead, Democrats are pushing impeachment.
and the media has returned to pejorative leaks,
which imply the president obstructed justice.
Barely hours after a political shooting,
the left wing and the media get right back on track with partisan attacks
and not a word of remorse for the climate of violence they did so much to create
Look, the tumultuous, polarized political climate we live in today,
is a problem.
Violent rhetoric and political hatred on both sides are disturbing.
and we should have conversations about how to simmer it down.
But this sort of ludicrous, hypocritical coverage from Fox and other right wing media,
only serves to exacerbate the root cause of this violence and hatred.
the problem they claim to be trying to solve.
For conservative pundits to sit around and cherry pick violent rhetoric or actions
from a few people who are, broadly speaking, ostensibly on the left,
while pretending that violent rhetoric is somehow unique to the left,
and a new phenomenon that the right is immune to,
is disingenuous at best and malicious at worst.
The dillusion and hypocrisy involved in this narrative,
are so striking that it's difficult to even know where to begin.
But let's start with the idea that the biggest threat of politcal violence today comes from the left.
and look at that claim empirically.
NPR recently talked to experts who study violence and extremism,
in order to fact check the claim that left wing political violence is on the rise.
NPR determined that, quote,
those who track extremism say that while there are a few far-left groups that raise red flags
their numbers remain small
The groups being referred to  largely fall under the umbrella of Antifa
short for Anti-fascist.
The NPR article describes antifa as, quote,
loosely affiliated groups of mostly young people
mainly on the west coast, but spreading around the country,
They dress in black and wear masks when they confront right-wing groups
In the past few months there have been clashes and confrontations in Berkeley, California,
Portland, Oregon, and more recently on the campus of Evergreen State College. in Olympia, Washington.
However these incidents have caused conservative pundits like Tucker Carlson,
to lose their minds, and use the ammunition to fan the flames of the quote,
violent left narrative.
Some of these antifa clashes since Trump was elected,
have resulted in broken property,
rocks being thrown, some minor injuries,
No one has been killed or seriously injured during any of these clashes, but nonetheless,
these sort of groups and their tactics should be condemned and monitored appropriately.
But Mark Pitcavage, a senior research fellow at the Anti Defamation League's Center on Extremism,
told NPR that the number of far-left, antifa type extremists,
is tiny in relation to the mainstream political left.
Quote, "the far left is very active in the United States."
"but it hasn't been particularly violent for some time."
"In the past 10 years when you look at murders committed by domestic extremists,"
"in the United States, of all types,"
"right-wing extremists are responsible for about 74% of those murders."
said Pitcavage to NPR.
This is the crazy part.
Despite the alarmism, and hysteria, and sensationalized fear-mongering,
about left wing violence
The empirical truth of the matter is that far right extremism,
has been and continues to be a far more significant threat
than far left extremism, even during the age of Trump and the "resistance"
Ryan Mauro, who I've interviewed before,
is a security analyst with the Clarion Project,
a right-wing think tank dedicated to, quote,
"Challenging Radical Islam"
appeared on Fox news recently and said, quote,
"Anyone that studies this kind of extremism or terrorism,"
"knows that whatever political party or philosophy does not control the White House, "
"The extremism rises on that side."
But even if we take Mauro at his word here,
right-wing extremism still remains a significantly greater threat
according to experts and all available statistics.
What exactly qualifies as right-wing or left-wing extremism?
What violent incidents are counted in the sum total?
How the severity of the threat is gauged?
These sorts of variables vary between organizations that study extremism.
But by any metric,
Right wing extremism is definitively, and undeniably a far greater threat.
So much so, that it's more or less on par with
the threat posed by jihadist, Islamic extremism in this country.
And you might be thinking, David, no way, that's an exaggeration,
fake news maybe.
Since 9/11 there have been more deadly attacks committed by far right extremists in the US
than by radical Islamists.
Although more people in total have been killed by Muslim terrorists.
According to figures from an exhaustive study by New America,
which have been updated into 2017
There have been at least 20 deadly attacks motivated by far right wing ideologies in the US since 9/11.
Resulting in the deaths of 53 people.
Comparatively, there have been 11 deadly attacks motivated by radical Islam,
resulting in 95 deaths.
To give you a sense of what sorts of incidents New America is categorizing as far right-wing attacks,
Some examples are the stabbing of two men in Oregon this year by Jeremy Joseph Christian,
an anti-Muslim, anti-Semitic, Nazi sympathizing bigot,
who was harassing a Muslim girl prior to the stabbing.
In March 2017, Timothy Caughman, a black man from New York City,
was stabbed to death with a sword, by James Harris Jackson, a white man from Baltimore, Maryland.
Who drove all the way to New York City,
with the sole purpose of killing a random and innocent African American.
In 2015, three people were killed in a Colorado Springs, Planned Parenthood Clinic
in a religiously motivated shooting.
And of course, 9 black Americans were killed in a Church
in Charleston, South Carolina by Dylan Rouf,  a white supremacist.
The list goes on and on, and these are just the deadly attacks that we're talking about.
It doesn't include assaults that result in death,
nor the dozens of right-wing plots that were foiled by law-enforcement.
Such as Robert Doggart, a former congressional candidate from Tennessee
who plotted to carry out an armed attack
against a Muslim majority town in rural upstate New York.
A study from the Investigative Fund and the National Institute that came out this year,
found that between 2008 and 2016,
far right plots and attacks outnumbered Islamic instances by almost 2 to 1.
The Southern Poverty Law Center has compiled a comprehensive list of right-wing terrorism plots and attacks
dating back to 1995.
and the sheer volume and regularity of these instances is striking.
This is a well established issue in the United States.
There's numerous available studies and reports going back over the years
that have all come to similar conclusions.
These studies include, a 2015 study from the Triangle Center on Terrorism and Homeland Security and Duke University,
titled, Law Enforcement Assessment of the Violent Extremism Threat,
a 2009 Department of Homeland Security study, titled,
Rightwing Extremism: Current Economic and Political Climate Fueling Resurgence in Radicalization and Recruitment
a 2012 congressional research service report, titled,
The Domestic Terrorist Threat: Background and Issues for Congress
a 2011 study done in conjunction between the Department of Homeland Security and
the national consortium for the study of terrorism and responses to terrorism,
and a 2002 FBI report to the senate intelligence committee.
Right wing, extremist violence is not just a problem in the United States,
just recently a far right extremist was arrested in France
for plotting to assassinate newly elected French president Macron in front of Donald Trump.
and said, after he was arrested, that he wanted to attack, quote, "Muslims, Jews, blacks, and homosexuals."
A right wing terrorist in the UK plowed a van into a crowd of people leaving a mosque in June
A rightwing extremist threw acid into the face of two Muslims in London
seriously maiming and disfiguring them
So yes, anti-Muslim, anti-black, anti-Semitic, anti-government,
anti-abortion,
ultra Christian type extremists
represent a similar threat to jihadist terrorism
and that threat is not going away any time soon.
Experts actually worry that Donald Trump's victory has emboldened these kinds of groups,
and we've seen early evidence of upticks in those types of hate crimes and attacks.
but Fox News and other right wing media outlets ignore this threat.
instead, focusing on the so-called violent left.
In fact, the notion that far right extremist represents a major threat,
is scoffed at on their network.
It's not just Fox News,
Far right wing extremism has been shamefully, a severely under reported issue in the mainstream media in general
Particularly when compared to the sensationalized, fear mongering coverage
of Islamic terrorism
Another terrifying facet of this, is that the Trump administration has recently frozen funding
slated by President Obama to go to organizations
that work to counter right wing extremism
but now, let's look at the claim being made by many on the right,
that the Liberal Media is complicit in this supposed rise of hatred and violence on the left
where we truly get to the height of hypocrisy,
Sean Hannity has said,
that liberals, particularly in the media,
have been dehumanizing and objectifying Republicans.
He also wrote in a column for Fox News, titled,
Left wing Haters Fan the Flames of Rage and Violence,
that they, referring I guess, to the left in general,
may not be responsible for violence, but they have a responsibility to dial down the hate
before more people get hurt.
Do you believe there's a link between the climate of hate for Muslims at Fox
and other conservative media, quote, did so much to create?
And the many attacks and plots against Muslim Americans,
perpetrated by far right radicals?
and Sean, you want to talk about dehumanizing and  objectifying people?
Look at how you've personally covered Muslims on your show
(Hannity): Here's what's eventually gonna happen
Eventually the world's gonna wake up to what I would say.
and every radical Islamist like you will be wiped off the face of the earth
(David): and look at how you talk about refugees.
(Hannity): ISIS and Al Qaeda, not if, they will infiltrate the refugee community,
this president is committed to nearly 250,000 coming to America.
(David): and just look at the kind of hateful, sometimes violent rhetoric, espoused by people
on your side during the 8 years that Obama was president.
"He's a secret Muslim that wants to enact Sharia Law,"
"He's a traitor, he hates America."
And this wasn't only a problem when Barack Obama was president
It's still a problem right now.
Within days of the shooting at the Republican baseball practice,
Former Republican congressman Joe Walsh tweeted,
"Screw talks of bipartisanship"
"This country is at war with itself.  Choose your side and choose it now"
"Grab your musket and get ready."
It's always wise not to throw stones when you live in a glass house.
and the audacity of these conservative pundits,
to lecture the left about toning down the rhetoric,
is incredible.
and it's just conservative pundits in the media.
I mean, Donald Trump himself has openly and brazenly
encouraged violence against demonstrators at his rallies.
(Trump): I love the old days. You know what they used to do to guys like that in a place like this?
They'd be carried out in a stretcher folks.
(applause)
(David): This rhetoric did materialize into real violence
A number of demonstrators exercising their right to free speech
that conservatives love to champion,
were assaulted and injured at Trump rallies
after Donald Trump literally called for it.
Trump campaign rallies often devolved into cesspools of depraved hatred.
Where legitimately vile, scornful, violent rhetoric
was openly espoused by Trump supporters.
Politico reported that during the campaign
that refrains of 'hang the bitch' and 'kill the bitch'
were growing increasingly common at Trump rallies, referring of course, to Hillary Clinton.
A Trump supporter was photographed wearing a shirt that said,
Rope. Tree. Journalist. Some assembly required.
Curt Schilling, a former major league baseball pitcher, turned conservative mouthpiece,
shared it on twitter, and thought it was funny.
Where were all of these conservative pundits talking about toning down the rhetoric then?
This widespread, hateful, anti-media rhetoric
has also materialized into real violence.
Then republican candidate Greg Gianforte,
body slammed a reporter
and then won a congressional race the next day.
We're not talking about dolls and plays here.
We're talking about instances of real, physical violence.
corresponding to legitimately hateful rhetoric that's widespread in conservative discourse.
And remember when Trump said,
that the second amendment people might need to
stop Hillary Clinton from appointing liberal justices to the Supreme Court?
(Trump): If she gets to pick her judges,
nothing you can do folks.
although the second amendment people, maybe there is. I dont know.
(David): Or when he had to fire his long time butler,
who wrote on facebook that Obama should be shot as an enemy agent.
Or when Trump said we should kill the families of terrorists and start torturing people again.
Or how about when secret service agents
had to interview a Trump campaign advisor
who said Hillary Clinton should be put in the firing line
and shot for treason
Or when his campaign adviser, Roger Stone,
tweeted, "Clinton must be brought to justice, arrested, tried, and executed for murder"
I could legitimately go on for hours citing countless examples of prominent conservatives
spouting legitimately hateful and violent rhetoric.
All the things Ted Nugent has said about Obama alone
could fill an entire show.
but just as a quick reminder,
(Nugent): I'll tell you this right now, If Barack Obama becomes president in November again,
I will either be dead or in jail by this time next year.
I will either be dead or in jail. Do you really find any ambiguity in that?
We need to ride into that battle field and chop their heads off.
I was in Chicago last week,
I was in Chicago, I said Hey Obama
You oughtta suck on one of these you punk!
(applause)
(David): Now that Donald Trump is on office, however,
Nugent is saying, quote, "we have got to be civil to each other."
That's all well and good, but conservatives can't pretend
that people from the right haven't been major contributors to the culture of hatred and violence
that they're currently railing against
now that their guy is in office.
And we're not even really going to get into how all of this is trivialized and excused by conservatives,
who tell liberals complaining about this type of behavior
that they're just triggered,
and a bunch of special snowflakes
who should go back to their safe spaces.
What's the truth?
Although there may be some legitimate reasons to be concerned about rhetoric on the left,
the possibility of mentally unstable people
who may take the idea of the resistance too far,
both hateful rhetoric and acts of political violence,
are disproportionately a problem on the right.
not the left.
This is yet another example of the major projection
that is common to right wing politics in the United States
If conservatives want to have a legitimate discussion about the political climate, civility, and rhetoric
They really have to take a look in the mirror first.